for my V is that deep on I'm bachelor I
mean you're welcome
[Music]
don't do it no I'm kidding Wow what
would I tell myself keep my mouth shut
probably more often than I did the first
season I was a little too opinionated
probably that's just who I am it's just
kind of getting used to each other and
in some ways you know Vanessa and I for
the most part have been living with each
other and that's obviously a big step in
any relationship you know we've
certainly been fast-tracking it from the
very time we met and so that certainly
has a lot of great excitement and also
there's a lot of like okay this is this
is really something no wedding plans yet
again you know Vanessa and I we're
taking things really slow and we're
happy to do that we've known each other
for less than a year now bachelor nation
has a bit of a backlog with engaged
couples so there's a plenty of couples
in line for us that have to tie the knot
before we do so this guy is this like
loving life you know when you find a
good spot on a couch you don't move
[Music]
you know I'm someone who kind of wears
like I'm nostalgic I just kept it on as
a kind of a momento or reminder to me of
like this this process potentially
working out now no not really my opinion
of Corinne definitely kind of changed
over the course the season while filming
but she was someone I even had a hard
time figuring out and I think kind of
America's opinion of Corinne and the
hotend that evolution was kind of almost
similar to mine
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah it sucked it it was heartbreaking
but the same time I knew and knew
Caitlin for about eight weeks you get
over the same way you kind of get into
it like it's rapid-fire and these
emotions once you remove yourself from
that environment you know well it's not
easy it probably goes quicker than say
someone who broke up with someone after
a two-year relationship or something
like that
[Music]
it couldn't be more fun and it's also
incredibly exhilarating to when you get
done with the dance you're like that was
amazing you don't think about the fact
that it's live and millions of people be
watching it that doesn't even cross your
mind it's just the fact that you're in
this big arena and it's filled with
people screaming and cheering and you're
about to do something you don't even
know what you're about to do and you
barely know your steps
I'm not a big planner so I don't even
know what I'm doing next week so five
years who the heck knows I don't see
myself doing much reality TV after this
you know Vanessa and I obviously are
going to focus on a relationship and
work on that and I have been lucky
enough to start my own business which
will be launching shortly it's just a
men's grooming line called the polish
gent that's going to be my my number one
priority outside of the relationship
with Vanessa and hopefully that takes up
most of my time these cute little
puppies are from Michaelson found
animals adopt and shop if you need a
magical puppy you should go to them but
they won't promise they'll save puppies
they'll become lovely dogs which are
also great
[Music]
Wow